breast cancer kills tens of thousands of
women in this country every year while
black and white women get breast cancer
at nearly the same rates women of color
are 40 percent more likely to die from
the disease denise valdez explains why
in our buddy check 8 report
well doctors are concerned the pandemic
will only widen that gap as many women
are delaying their mammograms black
women are also more likely to be
diagnosed before age 40 and that's when
annual screenings typically start dr
joanna folen is an ob gyn in las vegas
and a breast cancer survivor she urges
her patients to get their annual
screenings but also know your body so
you can discover changes no matter how
small i think that women should
definitely concentrate
on
um get doing their self breast exams
i think they should do it every month i
think they should do it a week after
their menses for black women breast
cancer is often found later which means
it's often more advanced dr vivian b is
an oncologist and warns younger
african-american women in particular are
more likely to present with the triple
negative subtype of the disease which is
both more aggressive and more deadly
while black women are slightly less
likely to be diagnosed with a breast
cancer compared to their white
counterpart they're 40 percent more
likely to die there are environmental
concerns too beauty products often
marketed to black women yet contain some
of the most worrisome ingredients
everything from skin lighteners to hair
relaxers and there is a list of product
types to avoid along with chemicals of
concern in this fact sheet and we have a
link to it on our website for buddy
check denise valdez live local now